we're so happy for you and then mouth
the two of you are a great couple and
you proved in descendants three that
you'll be a great ruler you can make
hard decisions and have learned to admit
when you're wrong you'll be a great
Queen but you are super young we don't
want you to rush into marriage until
you've really thought things through and
there are some loose ends you need to
tie up look at me
No look at me
Malan Bank got engaged in the sentence
three but mal is so young keep watching
to find out everything mal needs to do
before she ties the knot finish high
school
descendants 3 was a little unclear as to
whether mal had finished high school at
auradon prep we know that some students
including Audrey were at the school for
summer school if mal hasn't completed
her education she really needs to do
that becoming Queen requires a good
understanding of a lot of subjects she's
so close to her diploma mal needs to
graduate before she gets married turn 18
on a similar note we don't know exactly
how old Meryl is we know that Ben was
only 16 when he became king of auradon
but we aren't sure why auradon allowed a
high school student to become king if we
assume mal is close to the same age she
might not be eighteen yet in most
countries you need to be 18 to get
married otherwise you need your parents
stamp of approval we have a feeling
Hades and Maleficent might not one mal
getting married so young go to college
after graduating from auradon prep mal
should really consider going to college
she's super smart and being queen
requires a lot of knowledge about
politics in history C give it a bottle
correct College is also a great way to
figure out what you really want in your
life we're sure there are lots of
education options for mal in auradon
travel the world now lived on the Isle
of the lost until she was a teenager
then she went to Oregon which is really
just a few minutes away she doesn't know
anything about the rest of the world
traveling when you're young is a great
way to find yourself it helps you grow
up and get a new perspective
we'd love to see mal and Evie take a
backpacking trip together find herself
now has barely figured out who she truly
is she grew up thinking she'd spent her
whole life on the Isle as a villain
we know she loves bends but there's a
lot more to life than being in a
relationship does mal really want to
just be queen she might want to have
some sort of career outside of ruling
Oregon she might want to focus on
charities revive Maleficent last time we
checked Maleficent was still a lizard
now can't just keep her mother trapped
in a lizard's body forever
she needs to revive Maleficent and then
she and Ben need to figure out how to
keep Maleficent from going totally
berserk Maleficent and mal will need to
have a serious heart-to-heart
conversation we just hope Maleficent is
willing to be a good mom make peace with
Hades mal in Hades started making peace
at the end of descendants two but Hades
was absent mousehole life they have some
serious issues they need to get over
they don't know much about each other we
know Hades cares about mal but he
doesn't know how to be a dad we want
these two to get close now might even
want him to walk her down the aisle at
her wedding have important conversations
a happy marriage requires a lot more
than love
Ben and mal need to have some serious
conversations do they see their future
going in a similar direction do they
both want kids they need to figure out
how many kids they want and how they
want to parent they need to learn how to
overcome relationship challenges look at
me no look at me you love me no you
don't yes I do look at me
they definitely need to be discussing
their future goals we hope these two are
having hard conversations select your
wedding party once all the hard stuff is
done mal gets to plan her wedding it's
pretty much a given that Evy will be her
maid of honor but who else will be in
the wedding
she and uma were close when they were
younger but are they good enough friends
now for uma to be a bridesmaid mal might
want Carlos and Jay to stand on her side
but then might make them groomsman
there's a lot to consider say yes to the
dress
mal also needs to select the perfect
wedding dress
we know that Evy will design something
beautiful but she'll have to have a lot
of planning sessions with mouse mouse
dress needs to be perfect since it's a
royal wedding but it also needs to show
off a lot of her personality and then
there will be fittings and alterations
before she can say yes to the dress
what else do you think mouse should do
before she marries Ben let us know in
the comments thanks for watching be sure
to like this video and click that
subscribe button for more great content
from the things we'll catch you next
time
you